dracula would love to call his gothic
boarding house a five-star destination
but the reviews for hotel transylvania
suggested the place didn't offer much to
scream about
at least not for adults however there
are still plenty of
jokes themes and references specifically
for the grown-ups in the room
hotel transylvania brims with endearing
and inventive fantasy takes on the
little details of parenting
any adult who has ever changed a diaper
would envy dracula's ability to
telekinetically suspend a dirty diaper
in the air rather than having to touch
it
and for disposal purposes dracula has a
little diaper coffin which opens with a
foot pedal
with his ability to turn into a bat and
his use of this power to surveil his
daughter
dracula also gives new meaning to the
term helicopter parent
he even attempts to influence his
daughter mavis interest in romance and
the type of boy she should pursue
sweetheart there are so many eligible
monsters out there
in an amusing but bittersweet exchange
wayne werewolf asks his children to
track down
johnny the human but the hyperactive
pups have trouble focusing and obeying
his request
dracula solves the problem by inquiring
which of the werewolf's children still
respects him
the poor guy is painfully aware that
parental respect wanes like the moon
as children grow up fortunately wayne
knows exactly which one of his kids is
young enough to still listen to him
and want to help out during the
construction of the hotel audiences
might notice that all the construction
workers are zombies who
when you think about it would make ideal
workers or maybe it's the other way
around and the pursuit of being the
perfect worker can turn a person into a
zombie
either way many adults relate to the
struggle of punching a clock and
mindlessly toiling day in and day out
even past the point of exhaustion with
zombies though there is no point of
exhaustion
the undead don't need sleep or eat so
they would never require a lunch break
or a vacation day though in hotel
transylvania they aren't portrayed as
the completely inexhaustible labor
source they would potentially provide in
other fictional scenarios
exploring the extremes of zombies
possible utility is fascinating
nonetheless if bosses ever needed to
expand the staff
they could just send the zombies out to
infect new recruits
and there would be no workers comp
claims and no need for the employer to
take out workplace insurance because the
undead can't feel
pain humor may be another culprit in the
case of hotel transylvania's
less than stellar critical reception
there are a number of silly moments that
would typically be considered seriously
low brow
this shouldn't necessarily detract from
the film it does need
to appeal to kids after all and it's not
like the childish humor pretends to be
anything more sophisticated than it is
one gag which literally makes characters
gag is frankie framing murray the mummy
for passing gas
you're kidding me right in my lobby i
swear man
i i don't run like that but this joke
actually has some level of science
behind it
mummification is a 70-day process meant
to purify the body
including the removal of the intestines
stomach and other internal organs
which are placed in jars and entombed
along with the body
since murray has clearly left his
resting place it's safe to assume that
the organs that would facilitate his
breaking of the wind
aren't anywhere close by so unless an
embalmer
really messed up he's right he really
doesn't run like that
throughout the movie frankie voices an
intense fear of fire
imploring others to avoid situations
that might expose them to it
he even has a plane phobia because
engines can catch fire at any moment
yeah yeah fire bad we know
the hotel might seem like a safe place
since it doesn't seem to rely on
electricity
however it employs candelabras and
torches instead which
doesn't seem to bother frankie as much
as it should what only adults and
possibly high school english students
would notice
is that this fear is actually canon in
frankenstein the 1818 novel by mary
shelley
the creature is afraid of fire as well
he discovers that fire is truly
deceptive
its illuminating power brings discovery
and enlightenment but it also has the
capacity to harm and devastate
the literally enlightening nature of
fire parallels venturing into the real
world
which mavis desires to do as you become
an adult you see
so many new things but you'll also take
greater risks and face greater
challenges and
dangers sunlight is the bane of all
vampires
and fire is also what killed mavis
mother this is part of the reason
dracula tries so hard to keep her in the
dark
but on the other hand the beauty of a
glowing sunrise
which johnny helps her see for the first
time is what inspires her to give humans
a chance
throughout the film all the monsters
keep a close eye on human affairs in
order to remain apprised of emerging
threats which are always looming larger
literally one of the most alarming
developments is the fact that humans are
becoming
heavier while humans view obesity as a
threat to their own well-being
dracula sees it as a menace to his kind
the bigger people are
the more easy it is for them to
overpower monsters plus it makes their
blood much less healthy
human blood is so fatty and you never
know where it's been
some adults lament that kids these days
are shirking modesty and wearing less
clothing
but rather than being symbolic of a
societal decline as some members of
older generations of humans see it
in the eyes of monsters this behavior
actually makes people more powerful
it allows them greater freedom of
movement to strangle monsters
or cut their heads open to put candy in
which they can then
eat to grow to even more intimidating
sizes what
look at me i'm getting goosebumps i'm so
scared
the supernatural world offers a lot of
opportunities to joke about growing up
that holds special meaning for those who
have actually gone through it
the turning point of adulthood for
immortal vampires comes at 118 years of
age
instead of 18. of course in terms of
eternity this doesn't make much sense
18 is about a quarter of the average
human lifespan
and although a quarter of infinity isn't
technically possible to determine
it would probably be greater than 118.
not to mention the idea of immortality
revolves around not aging at all but
non-aging would undermine the entire
theme of the movie so we don't worry
about that
the joke is that there is a
coming-of-age point for vampires that
presents
similar challenges to those of
adolescent humans and their parents
there are also a lot of one-liners in
hotel transylvania that reference
various recognizable points along the
human path to adulthood
mavis protests that she deserves
independence because she's old enough to
drive a hearse
another comment references mavis being
barely out of training fangs which could
allude to anything from training bras to
training wheels to braces
and in another plea for autonomy she
points out that she's not
83 anymore still even though she's 118
years old it doesn't prevent mavis from
pulling a childhood trick that always
helps to change her father's mind
come on no no don't do that don't give
me the pouty bad face
by the time she turns 118 mavis has
prepared for a showdown with her father
regarding her right to explore the world
as an adult
which is why she is incredulous when she
doesn't even get the chance to launch
into her argument
before her father agrees to her wishes
this seeming reversal surprises the
audience too
as dracula has explicitly stated that he
constructed the hotel in order to keep
his daughter safe at home forever
without any reasons to leave of course
we find out that when he recommends a
nearby human village to visit
it's actually because he had it
constructed specifically for her
basically the entire village is a ruse
dracula has enlisted a gaggle of zombies
to pose as humans
and play out every terror he warned
mavis about hoping to scare away her
desire to explore the rest of the world
the zombie is dressed up as the town's
people
luckily for dracula it works mavis flies
away
frightened and disappointed as she takes
to the sky it appears that the clock in
the town square reads midnight
however we don't hear any bells which
would align with the fact that the
village is just a facade
midnight is a significant hour in the
world of monsters but it also signifies
the transition to a new day
prompting an association with a new
chapter of adulthood
the passage of one day to the next
highlights the fact that time moves
relentlessly onward no matter how hard
someone
especially a parent wants to cling to
the way things are
although they call themselves monsters
the subjects of this film
unsurprisingly define this term much
differently than the way humans do
in fact in their minds the roles are
reversed they see humans as terrifying
and dangerous savages
but most of the monster's habits and
behaviors have clear analogs in the
human world
the monsters have a clear sense of
morality that most humans would
recognize
they harbor no desire to hurt others and
place a strong emphasis on family ties
social connections and loyalty all in
all the monsters are pretty similar to
most of the humans they so desperately
fear
in fact dracula has adopted his own
brand of veganism
even if this was only written for the
sake of a one-liner it references his
use of blood alternatives in place of
killing and draining humans
dracula doesn't drink blood no i use a
blood substitute
either near blood or blood beaters you
can't tell the difference
children who don't spend much time in
the beverage or dairy aisles of grocery
stores probably won't get the joke which
riffs on non-alcoholic near beer and a
healthier egg substitute called egg
beaters still that's just one of the
film's
many quick puns and gags that will fly
over the heads of younger viewers
but give parents something to chuckle
about oh i'm sorry i'm a little lost
yes i know it's your honeymoon i
apologize go back to doing what you were
doing
after johnny the human is disguised by
dracula he claims to be frankie's cousin
from his right arm
side of the family in shelley's novel
victor frankenstein discovered a way to
bring life to dead matter
but rather than simply raise the dead he
wants to animate the ideal humanoid
as a result he seeks out the most
beautiful version of each body part
the most appealing face might not come
from the same body as the
ideal arm leg or hand which is why each
part sewn into the creature's form comes
from a different person
obviously each of these people has a
different backstory and has left
their own family behind meaning that
frankenstein probably has a dozen or
more sets of relatives
shelley's creature never sought out his
ancestors
but it's a concept that hotel
transylvania humorously explores
however it would probably be a little
overwhelming for frankie to sit back
and really ponder the past lives of his
body parts
that was trippy
for many adults it's tough to hear the
title hotel transylvania and not think
of the eagles 1976 hit song
hotel california it's been a staple of
classic rock radio and cover bands for
decades
one of the track's most iconic lines
states that you can
check out anytime you like but you can
never leave
similarly vampires mummies ghosts and
zombies have
checked out of the world of living but
they can never leave their immortal life
mavis wants to go where her parents met
in hawaii a place called paradise
which also alludes to the home of the
eternal afterlife if you're lucky
but you can never leave is also how
dracula feels about mavis growing up
and leaving home to visit paradise or
anywhere else
while there's plenty of music in hotel
transylvania the eagles never get a
shout out
however another band who most kids have
probably never heard of
gets a quick mention i have so many
places i want to see
i've got tickets to six state matthews
band concerts check out one of our
newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and tv shows are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one